[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] them
[Music]
happy hump day
one of our favorite days here on the
tony michaels podcast pump
day i don't know if it's just because
it's called hump day or like halfway
through the week
i don't know
but happy
happy hump day to everyone out there
everyone's here this morning holy moly
we have carter we have nolan we have
kevin we have christina we have kathy
uh everyone's here this morning welcome
welcome welcome to the show you know
every single weekday noon eastern 11
central right here on youtube twitter
twitch
don't forget to subscribe and like and
all the things i'm supposed to say for
the youtube thing whatever it is you can
also watch us on twitter
again if you're if you're not paying
attention
we are now on the minds touch media
network so you can go to their page as
well to see the broadcast there you can
see it on our page at tonymichaelspod
on twitter so follow us there hopefully
we'll have a bonehead of the week pull
out this afternoon there's plenty of
[ __ ] boneheads and there'll be more
and more and more as the day ticks on
you've seen this morning that president
zielinski the president of ukraine
addressed the united states congress
which i'm sure i'm sure vladimir putin
got big jelly that the republicans
didn't invite him
which who knows maybe maybe there is
some kind of secret deal in a back
republican gqp room somewhere that would
love to have vladimir putin come and
address them in congress
they love vladimir putin absolutely love
him he's a great leader to them
i mean you know the murderous dictator
thing they love that part they love that
part
you know the whole fascist thing
speaking of fascist i have a clip that i
want to play for you guys today
of uh
a lieutenant governor of idaho
apparently
associate yourself with nick fuentes
the uh america first nazi you know you
know i'm talking about the one that
marjorie taylor green went to eight pack
whatever the hell that is
uh the nazi rally
and decided that maybe that wasn't such
a good idea
the idaho lieutenant governor has now
associated herself which they all are
nick fuentes is the republican party
that's who it is
nick fuentes is the republican party
they can't run from this guy
they keep saying oh well his following
is such a great fight yeah that's who it
is that's your constituents that's who's
[ __ ] voting for you that's who you're
courting to vote for you that's who you
want
the republicans
are nick fuentes's audience
that's who they want so i got that clip
to play for you we also have a great
interview today with dakota adams
you've seen dakota on the show several
times he is the estranged son of oath
keepers founder
that terrorist group
and that terrorist stewart rhodes
that is indicted for
seditious conspiracy we've seen one of
his cohorts as the oath keeper um plea
guilty
and i wanted to have uh dakota on to
speak about that also there's a couple
other things in the news about seditious
conspiracy that ties to stuart rhodes
so i wanted to have dakota on to get his
ideas and his thoughts
about stewart rhodes
and those ties to seditious conspiracy
since we have all that going on in the
news as we see tario is arrested as we
see james has uh uh pled guilty and
seditious conspiracy so
stick around during the second hour we
will play that interview
but first off
we have one of our favorites here today
with us rachel bitkoffer everyone knows
rachel and she she she's
she's always on twitter pounding
messaging messaging messaging messaging
and the one thing i want to do is i want
to show rachel this video
of this lieutenant governor
trying trying to wipe the fascism off of
her
as this local reporter
uh uh asked her questions in in
fantastic style and and all journalists
can learn a lesson out there rachel how
are you
i'm great tony as you know i've chosen
today to live stream from my favorite
location in eugene
skinner's butte which is this beautiful
beautiful view that you guys oh my god
yeah look at that i would panoramic it
but i figure it's enough you guys have a
train whistle in the background to deal
with even better even better to set the
scene you know we we love when you do
from the pickup truck but i don't know
this this may one up the pickup truck
rachel i think so man i gotta tell you i
didn't come up here near enough before i
was forced into expatting for grad
school and it's not a mistake i'll be
making twice tony you'll be going back
is what you're saying yep that's awesome
it is a great view it's a great view
there so how are you feeling i know you
had a trip to texas here recently uh you
were talking about that on twitter is
there anything you'd like to tell us
about that trip from texas
yeah you know it's always nice to go to
the republic of texas you know it's like
you know second second ground zero of
the gop state level like fascist
takeover of a competitive state they're
much more condensed in places where
gnome has you know like south dakota
north dakota idaho like they're actually
even worse up in those places but nobody
gives a [ __ ] because no one lives there
right uh florida texas ground zero of
coved uh genocide basically so i went
down there to try to light a fire into
the progressive community and explain to
them look everything you're doing down
here in texas matters insofar as trying
to set a national narrative
that turns 2022 a referendum on the gop
right and if there's one person that
gets this referendum it's better as a
campaigner he's you know the campaign is
definitely
you know tying it all to
this is what happens when republicans
are in charge of your health wealth and
safety and that's the strategy that
everyone needs to be using in their
messaging right now
he is he he does seem to be uh striking
cords down there um i know it's going to
be an uphill battle and we talked about
the uphill battle for him before but i
mean the g the gqp in texas the fascists
in texas are basically handing this to
the democrats uh rather they know it or
not i mean they're they're they they
passed the the bounty hunter law and now
they're they're floating a law that
would make it uh to where the texas
could give a uh a person who would
have even uh a medical procedure that
would save their life
to kill them these are the pro-life
people these are the right to life right
exactly right and and you know that
those these issues coming out of texas
coming out of florida they're absolutely
um ripe for wedging uh all it takes is a
design it's not hard to wedge an issue
if you know how to do it and i do i've
studied gop anatomy for a long time um
and we need to you know
let people understand these risks
personal risk not something that might
happen to a trans child over there right
they're using the state the power of the
state government to weaponize child
protective services
to come and basically put political
pressure on people who want to accept
their kids for who they are right
even even just even just for someone to
have the thought and and to to try to
say hey i want to receive counseling for
these thoughts that i might be having
these feelings and i might be having
even just the simple care that the
actual counseling care of that would
trigger what they're talking about to
ostracize not just not just the people
who are having these thoughts but their
parents and their other siblings like to
totally ostracize him from society if
you don't understand what fascism is
maybe you should go all over to the
google machine and look it up that is
exact definition not only that they want
to take away women's liberty and then if
women and act on their liberty either in
texas or another state they want to give
them the death penalty these are
pro-lifers by the way dude and they also
want to give rapists the ability to
keep you from aborting a baby sue for
custody after they raped you i mean to
me that's a [ __ ] nightmare to be
honest with you as a rape survivor the
idea that i'd be forced to bear to term
my rapist baby and then share custody
with them hell [ __ ] no tony right
well did you see sorry the trains going
there no that's okay did you see did you
see the uh there was a video from the
tennessee legislator where they're
talking about a bill um you know florida
wants to out texas texas texas wants to
out florida florida and now you have
tennessee you have missouri piling on
we've seen a bill floated in the
missouri legislature where they want to
make it illegal for a woman to even
leave the state of missouri to receive a
medical procedure
we've seen a video in missouri where the
the person who's writing the bill that
makes it illegal for a woman to receive
a procedure for an eptopic pregnancy he
was asked do you even know what an
eptopic pregnancy is he's like nope
don't care don't give a [ __ ] why would i
care i'm not gonna get a i a man would
never have an eptopic pregnancy right so
what does he give a [ __ ] until his
daughter needs the surgery or is gonna
die right and then he'll be like oh [ __ ]
did i [ __ ] that up right so like we
can't afford for every republican to
have a gay child or you know need a
abortion because of an ecotopic
pregnancy and what we do need to do is
make sure that norms the norms out there
because again if you hear me and tony
every day or even occasionally you are
not a normal person you are not a modal
american
our job is as highly informed and
engaged individuals is to find a
mechanism by which we can convey this
collective narrative of gop government
onto normal people and make them fear
that change right you have to make
people fear change in 2022 and define it
as something that is going to endanger
them personally
well and i think i think also the other
thing that we have to do is try to find
a way to draw those wedges in between
what what is the old guard right the
thin veil fascism right what debts
deficits all that [ __ ] because they
never really truly believed any of this
and we now know this we have to find a
way to draw a wedge in between the old
guard thin veiled fascism and this
outright fascism that we have now and
make them make them fight amongst
themselves like they always make us
fight right we're always fighting over
is it 15 an hour eighteen dollars an
hour not me tony
i like them
let them let them fight amongst
themselves and we can draw those wedges
by asking these questions to the what
wants to be the old guard and that
doesn't want to say the quiet part out
loud and you know they're they're not
with this quiet part out loud make them
answer for the people who are saying the
quiet part out loud that's exactly right
if we tie all of them to it and define
the whole party as marjorie taylor green
josh halley ron desantis then these
people then finally have a vested
interest in controlling their own party
one of the big failures that we're
suffering through right now politically
is the inability of the republican party
to police itself in any capacity so if
you look at the cuomo scandal um you
know the democratic party was slow to
respond there's no [ __ ] doubt about
that guys but at the end of the day
it responded and pushed him out with a
super majority basically in new york
state they didn't do it because they had
to do it they did it because they had to
do it for per for to maintain
uh legitimacy in their own caucus so you
know and the gop had that mechanism as
long back as like 2014. i remember uh
even this guy that's running for
missouri senate will probably be the
next senator to join holly in that two
in that two-person senate caucus is eric
greitens and he was pushed out of the
governorship from missouri for black
sexual blackmail okay and they at that
time the republican party still had
enough [ __ ] dignity to kick his ass
out okay
now he's the front runner for the senate
and they will vote for him at the same
[ __ ] rates they voted for doug jones
down in alabama it doesn't matter what
these people do there's no internal
police now and that is incredibly
dangerous for america
well you know i know a bit about
eric greitens because i'm from missouri
and uh i actually have i actually have a
lot of
insight into eric greitens that i'd love
to share with you uh off air um that
maybe maybe we could talk about because
yeah i actually i actually uh know a lot
about eric greitens and the uh the the
absolute delusion that that guy lives
under um he is he's a frightening
individual yes but you know what you
know what you know what the gqp loves
they love frightening individuals
fascists fascists love scary people like
they love they love scary people do
scary things no [ __ ] i mean look at what
desantis has done down there in florida
man he's like picked up trump's
mannerisms he's rump he's wearing these
frumple looking ensues with slowly
increasingly brilliant red in the tie
he he copies his cadence now
he does the hand side he does that [ __ ]
dude it's [ __ ] up because it's so
stupid right it's somebody who's
studying goals and you know all of this
like propaganda history it is but it's
so stupid let me tell you it will work
it is working for him it is going to
work that's why he's doing it
you know it as as much as he's really
trying hard it is a really shitty trump
impersonation by the way it's not that
great i mean he's getting better at it
but it really is one of the shittiest
trump impersonations i've seen but he is
but don't doubt desantis he's he's
banging up florida he's really trying
hard um to to not only to not only uh
hurt floridians but to ostracize
children children in florida yep and if
you guys missed uh my partner dougie
crunched some numbers and we put out
this data uh it shows that florida's
death rate is seven times higher than
dc's okay
it's three times higher than
california's and basically the same for
new york and that's kind of a problem
guys like when you look when you control
for post vaccine because keep in mind
the first wave of kovid rushes in kills
a [ __ ] ton of people in the urban metros
that's march by the time it starts to
spread out to april that's when the
republican party's like [ __ ] it we gotta
reopen everything right so like they
reopen
it literally as the first wave is
peaking down in in florida and in
georgia and other places and that's why
we ended up with a wildfire infection
rate that we could never control
once vaccines come out though death is
frankly preventable i mean nine out of
10 people dying now are not vaccinated
so it's fairly preventable and they have
just let it rip i mean they they have
led their own constituency to their own
to to death and and we got to make ron
desantis answer for that
well i i agree and i think we can i
think we can tie all these republicans
together i want to show you this clip of
this idaho lieutenant governor um as as
she tries to explain how she's not a
nazi it's it's beautiful it's beautiful
let's let me play it here real quick um
it is a little long it's about four
minutes okay but but let's let's play it
i'll pause it a few places where we can
commentate so let's listen are you
familiar with who puts this event on
like nick fuentes
i don't i don't know who he is i don't
i've never met him i don't know who he
is did you not look into it before you
decided to say okay like to find out i
mean his name is on it
well you know what nick fuentes i don't
as i said i don't know him he he's never
this is really convenient right like
like oh he's just coffee boy right like
this is the coffee boy schtick like i
have no idea who he is never never heard
of the guy then why did you why did you
associate with him at all like you
google him right right
right right like a quick a quick search
would you would know that nick fuentes
not only is has anti-semitic ideas he
isn't he is the anti-semite yeah he is
he is it for them he's ground
[ __ ] zero dude
right right he
not only that he he is palling around
with people like marjorie taylor greene
lauren bobert paul goes out for
oh she knows let's watch some more
that's right that's right
i've never met him i don't know
i don't know
where the photo will come out this
weekend he says well there's photos
there's photos does not reflect on who i
am or who the thousands of others that
are participating in this
movement
you didn't bother to look up his name i
didn't say that
you did look him up
you didn't that's not the question that
you asked me
he just asked who fuentes was and what
he he what he's talked about like what
he thinks he has said
i have since
since
last week not before yes okay i guess
the question is because you if you've
said well i'm only and it's not fair
i mean you the mainstream media
you do this to conservatives all the
time
but you don't do it to yourself that oh
this is this is beautiful [ __ ]
fascist are you stupid
you know
it's crazy it's crazy to think that that
oh it's unfair it's unfair to ask the
question when i associate myself with a
no nazi with a known fascist a white
supremacist it is it is unfair for you
to ask me that question as the press
yeah it's not you doing your job it's
not a notable story you know it's like
come on dude these people just crack me
up man
i mean i mean but this is this is a a
good example of a local reporter
actually doing what you're supposed to
do and and really really getting at the
heart of the issue not what did you talk
about or no
right like look you are you are
associating with a nazi
right it's not it's it's not like um i i
i was i was small
and i was young when
george h.w bush ran for president the
first time and if you remember history
david duke if anyone's not familiar with
david duke he was a grand wizard of the
case and man bush was like disgusted
dude right
well the entire the entire republican
party basically basically
sent david duke out to pasture yes they
did for all intents and purposes said
yeah we cannot have this we cannot be
even close to have the stench
of the kkk on us like for for decades
and decades and decades
with the democratic party you know when
you get this [ __ ] a lot from the right
they're like oh well the democrats are
the ones they were we're the kkk like
yeah but you're you're you're negating
all the history in between no it's the
same people tony it's right it's
conservative exactly exactly the party
allegiance completely flips around in
that realignment guys but the [ __ ]
people are the same okay
southern white conservatives
and the crazy part is
george h.w bush understood that in the
political landscape and knew that holy
[ __ ] i want those people's votes but i
can't let the rest of the country know
that i'm with david duke no no i want
david duke's vote i can't do that like
we won't win that way that was that was
the whole southern strategy oh no [ __ ]
and not going to tell you like one of
the things that defines never trump i
mean it is it was the abject total
[ __ ] danger neon flashing signs of
putting somebody with trump's
personality failure of intellect
self-control all of those attributes
that failed the commander-in-chief test
of the role of the president that first
freaked no never trump out but the other
component is that people like jen rubin
and tom nichols and bill crystal are
very vested into racial pluralism okay
they joined into that coalition in the
1970s 1980s at a time period where the
party was very desperate to disassociate
itself with racial tension policies and
duke and you know so they they find
this as morally
um reprehensible as we do and thank god
because they're such important alley
allies right now in the fight to
maintain democracy here
well and and and i've been saying this
for a long time is that that democrat
the democratic party the pro-democracy
party because that's really where we're
at right now we're we're at a point
where the two parties in our country one
is for democracy one is for autocracy
one wants a fascist state one wants
democracy they want freedom they want
liberty and
and when when you're
when you're trying to decide which party
you're in right now
it is really easy to decide we should
make that even easier for these people
and then you know that's what we do with
this new ad i mean you know it's this is
a frame that i want to carry across the
cycle and i want everyone to be carrying
this banner it's not a straight pack
frame autocracy versus democracy the
tocracy republican party democracy the
democratic party it ain't [ __ ]
complicated
right you got your choice do you do you
want a dictatorship or do you want
liberty and then you gotta make that
dictatorship feel personal and you i
mean you really do you got to make it
feel like it's not going to be brown
people or asian people or whatever you
know you got it it's unfortunate
democrats at the end of the goddamn day
that white vote is really important and
white people are like any other group
they're going to be motivated mostly by
by descriptive representation and we
have to be making them personally fear
in suburban america what will happen to
them under republican control and their
children and it's not that hard because
the republicans are handing us this
stuff oh no [ __ ] it's not hard at all
tony i mean i want because can never
reiterate enough i know exactly how to
do it i can do it all [ __ ] day okay
call me because we need to do it
well i i'll tell you that uh that i
think i think in every state in every
republican-controlled state they're
going to keep out floriding florida
right and out of texas out texas texas
and they're going to keep going they're
not going to stop
and and i mean we're at the point where
they're talking about giving people the
death penalty for receiving a medical
procedure that's we're not even to the
bad part tony don't you remember if they
had found a way to either win or steal
2020 and stall trump in that if that
coup had succeeded
a big chunk of republicans conservative
you know voters and electeds had
invested in this cue phenomenon this qan
and phenomenon and the big portion of
their platform was re-elect truck trump
and then come after all of the people
all of the opposition jail them and
execute them
i mean
he's saying he's saying it on stage he's
saying
trump had a rally and all but said i'm
running in 2024 and what i want to do is
be a dictator like yes he's saying it
out loud
and all all the people out there
listening all the pro-democracy people
out there listening whether you think
you are a republican or a democrat or an
independent or moderate if you're for
democracy if you're for voting if you're
for not the government telling you what
the [ __ ] to do
just understand that 2022 is just as
important if not more important than
what 2024 will be and likely we will be
saying the same thing in 2024 that we're
saying right now that 2022 is the most
important in 2024 it will be we don't
win here tony we i mean how do you win
uh how do you have a 24 election with
these people okay these people who are
they've shown us who we are and i
[ __ ] believe them who they are and i
believe them we must believe them can
you imagine if they flip one of these
midwestern states michigan pennsylvania
wisconsin or all three and a new
republican governor of michigan is asked
to
you know administer freely and fairly
the 2024 presidential cycle [ __ ]
ain't gonna happen
ain't gonna happen right so so
everything is 22. we have to win right
[ __ ] here right [ __ ] now
and and the way we do that is not just
not just the united states house and
senate those are the most important
races probably but we also have
governor's races and we have down ballot
races too where not only can we make
change on the federal level but these
states need our help these people in
these states pro-democracy and democracy
in these states need our help like those
in florida are like okay well if we
can't have a fascist state in the
federal government we'll just make one
here in the state of texas and the state
of florida and
i and i think more and more people in
the state are understanding that big
government isn't just the federal
government like it's not like they've
always considered the federal government
the quote-unquote big government but
here uh in this in this timeline in this
crazy [ __ ] timeline that we're in big
government is is ron desantis is greg
abbott
is is
eric schmidt in in missouri who is the
attorney general who kept suing and
suing and suing school boards
to do what they wanted to do
and and ron desantis and greg abbott
were suing local governments local
governments they've always said all
small governments how we want nope
that's not what they want yeah that's
not what they've ever wanted no true
conservative could ever endorse a crt
ban which is a point i made recently to
somebody very special we may talk about
again soon you know there's literally
it's anti-fucking thetical all right if
you're going to have the government
surveil citizens several teachers
teacher tip lines you know rape victims
getting sued by the rapist this [ __ ] is
big government as [ __ ] tony right right
well i mean it's it's fascist it's big
government it's it's the exact big
government that they they've always been
warning us about and honestly maybe they
were projecting because it really does
seem like they've always been projecting
doesn't it yeah there's no way jack's
better than today's republican party
that's for sure dude that's that's right
that's right rachel i really do
appreciate you joining us and yeah let
me just give you guys the panoramic real
quick because i got you look at the view
look at this i want you guys to see
why i was so sad not to live here
for so so painfully long
isn't it nice
it's beautiful it's beautiful
thank you
thank you for joining us rachel love you
guys i'm back next week we'll have you
on next week uh we'll be and everyone
stick around we'll be right back after
this break
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker convoy
there's tammy
by the time we reached dc we was 50
strong in number
some patriots ran out of gas along the
way
we got plenty of slim jims
skull
near run out natty light
hope it don't rain tomorrow
so we can circle the city again
here's
bob
dear bob
i'm fixing to send you some more of them
doritos you like the red bag not the lid
loving blue one
in your absence i discovered a rash on
my neck and no it ain't no hickey and i
even seen my cousin brody in ages
stay strong
wipe your ass at least once a day
ears
tammy
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
always love having rachel big golfer on
giving us her
two cents three cents five cents
[Music]
on everything that's going on
giving us a bit of dose of how to
message
you know that's that's always the big
complaint
uh out there is uh how to message
democrats suck at messaging right well
it's not that it's not the democrats
socket messaging it's just democrats
suck at being all on the same team
they have to all be on the republicans
have always been good at this right
they set everything aside they have one
little nugget that they all run around
with every single day and one little
chicken nugget
and that chicken nugget is a thing they
all gather around and they all be a team
around that one thing you know they pick
one thing out that they can be a team
around and no matter what they got to be
around that thing now here's the thing
normally what they're what they're a
team around is a [ __ ] lie
it's [ __ ] lie it's fascism it's all
[ __ ] right it always has been like
rachel said they're not actual
conservatives they're not conservative
it's always been uh thin veiled fascism
dressed up as conservative listen during
the pandemic
a real conservative like a real
conservative like by definition
would have wore a mask would have social
distance
like that's conservative stuff that's
not liberal stuff that's conservative
stuff
like that's a conservative viewpoint
of a virus
like a liberal viewpoint of the virus
like ah just let everyone get it
no big deal
if if it it'll work itself out in the
wash right
why do you think why do you think so
many uh anti-vaxxers come from the left
side originally
it's because it's a very liberal
like the definition of the word
thing
politically
politically it may not be liberal
but what the reason why so many liberals
during the pandemic took it seriously
they wore mass they social distance they
listened to the science they listened to
doctors and then and then once the
vaccine came out they did the same thing
the reason why
is because
it made sense to be conservative in that
moment
right
it made sense to conserve the life that
we had in this country
by wearing mass social distancing uh
doing lockdowns um
working from home doing all the things
we did to sacrifice
during the time to make sure that we
weren't just needlessly killing off
hundreds of thousands of our citizens
and then when
the vaccine came along
we decided
the majority of the country decided well
we're going to take this conservative
measure and conserve what we still have
to fend off the virus
it's not liberal to take vaccines
it's not
you i mean you know it may feel good for
the left to think it's liberal but it's
it's not
it's it's not
but in the moment in the moment it made
sense to be conservative and for
everyone to to keep that in mind when
there's a deadly pathogen running around
schools running around your communities
killing people younger and younger
younger as these variants came about in
our country
and as these [ __ ] spread necks
spread it around our country
it was a conservative thing to do to
take in mind when you were getting your
vaccine and most people it wasn't a hard
decision it's a very easy decision some
folks it was a little harder
to make that decision
but it's it was conservative to do that
not liberal
with the boosters coming about that's
the same thing
the point i'm trying to make is that
these people don't know what these words
mean and they've never
never been conservative they have never
been do not let them get away with
calling themselves that uh we have we
have gay beer gabe's joining us hey gabe
how are you
what's up
yeah yeah did you did you catch any of
the uh uh were you busy or did you catch
any of the conversation we had with them
no i was i was busy yeah yeah well i i i
did i here i did here's a at the start
of the
the stream i saw rachel she looked like
she was on some ranch or something yeah
yeah she was like in a in a park where
she had this big scenery i told her i
said i like the i like the truck right
but the uh the panoramic view yeah you
know
she topped the pickup truck she really
yeah i i was like you know i don't know
where you are right now but i feel like
you know she's she's getting deeper and
deeper into like the
you know like the
uh
you know like uh
like a real
you know like uh like a like a it looks
like a conservative kind of uh american
like in a truck right on it right be
servant
ranch you know maybe maybe it's the
point i'm trying to make because
you you went through the pandemic as we
all did right yeah yeah so when you were
when you were making these decisions
when you were making these decisions
number one
um you you live in los angeles so
they had a little bit different uh uh
lockdown than some of the other parts of
the country right you guys had a little
different than than me here in missouri
meet here in missouri they were like
[ __ ] that [ __ ] yeah we yeah we actually
had a lockdown well i mean i don't want
to say like an actual lockdown because
that's not to say that we weren't like
nowhere in the country was like uh a new
zealand-esque lockdown right we didn't
take it as seriously as we should have
right
but we took it
relatively serious in terms of protocols
but still like probably not as good as
we could have done
well so my question is this
when you first started when because we
didn't know much about the virus let's
face it right
so were you like like when you first
found out hey this this is probably a
deadly thing were you like meh
let's just see how it turns out let's
not worry about any kind of
protocols let's not worry about washing
hands let's not worry about any of that
that stuff let's be hippies
and let's do the leftist thing right no
right yeah i'm fortunate enough to have
a mom who is a nurse
and i've spent years uh
whether it was myself as a patient in
the hospital or just like hanging around
the hospital so i know
and have picked up on things but at the
same time like
you know i i'm wise enough to
uh
to talk with my mom about it right like
especially what happened you know she
unfortunately had covet in april you
know um and was dealing with that
and she told me like one of her first
experiences with at the hospital was
with the patient who a son brought his
dad in
he was he was seen treated for kobit you
know a couple days later he's on a
respirator or a ventilator and then he
died
a few days later the sun dropped off the
mother
and similar kind of just like downfall
trajectory and she passed away
and never everyone at the hospital was
kind of going about it and then one of
the people were like you know
who brought these people in like who's
the next of kin
i'm like oh it was their son
and like has anyone checked on the sun
and when they finally did check on the
sun they found the sun uh he had died
uh of complications from covid in the in
the home he was 21
healthy like that's the the kind of
thing that makes you think like this is
a real [ __ ] problem that we've got
going on and we have to be serious about
it and for all the people who are like
it's a hoax it's whatever it's no worse
than the flu the
the flu is even is worse than this like
all these numbers are just are inflated
those people can go [ __ ] off because
uh i know people that have passed and as
well as my
mom has treated people in the hospital
from this and has been you know
direct directly connected and affected
by those people because of of covet and
so
that was just one story and that was all
the way back in
[Music]
end of march early april i think is when
she told me about um
about that story which i was like oh
[ __ ] this is serious i mean i took it
seriously beforehand but like hearing a
story like this i'm like yeah this is
right
right right exactly but your reaction
wasn't well you know a liberal
standpoint you had a conservative
whether you want to admit it or not you
took a conservative standpoint which
most americans did because they were
like well this is deadly we need to take
this serious we need to not we need to
not just let this spread around
liberally we need to be conservative
about it and try to conserve the health
of the nation
but it only proves that they're not
conservative the other thing that proves
that they're not conservative is what
rachel was saying just on the interview
they're not for small government that's
all [ __ ] that's all [ __ ] [ __ ]
when we look at some of the laws that
texas is out trying to florida florida
florida's out trying to texas texas now
we have we have missouri piling on we
have um uh so many of these other states
piling on with these laws really trying
to strike at people's liberty um and i
believe that their test they're they're
using these especially these anti-woman
bills because that's exactly what they
are
is anti-woman bills they're trying to
use these anti-woman bills as a testing
ground to see how far they can push
their fascism inside the state and
rachel's right that is the que that is
the definition of big government right i
i think i think people have always got
this confused that the federal
government is the big government no
no it's any government taking away your
liberty right when you're taking away
your liberty
that is big government when the
government is getting involved into
outlawing your liberty rather it be
rather it be through this stupid [ __ ]
loophole where they they they put
bounties on uh women's heads in texas uh
for having a medical procedure or
threatening them with [ __ ] the death
penalty or in missouri threatening them
with felonies if they leave the state to
get a medical procedure because frankly
in missouri they have to leave the state
to get medical procedures because it's
there is no facilities in missouri that
can give them those procedures it really
is it really is and i don't know did you
see this uh video maybe we should play
it here real quick before we play the
interview uh in tennessee uh i don't
know if you've seen uh there's a law in
tennessee they're trying to pass that is
very that is very uh similar to the law
in texas but apparently this law in
tennessee allows a rape victim
um
to to be sued by the family members of
their rapists the rapists can't sleep
i'm i'm dead serious let me see if i can
find it i think i have it on my timeline
here um but there is a there's a video
out there uh and it is official uh
debate on the floor in the tennessee
legislator
that is
that is insane
well i know what the [ __ ] the fact that
that the the the person the antagonist
in the situation
could then have their next of kin go you
know what not only did they [ __ ] over
this person mentally and physically
we're not going to [ __ ] them over
financially like
what what is the right reasoning like
what what what
you know duress or or pain
is the victim
putting on the family of the rapist well
and what they're trying to do apparently
with the law is make it to where um the
woman can be punished uh financially
it's the same it's the same idea in uh
in in texas right where they can make
here we go um here's the video here let
me
uh recount had the video
uh let's see let me play it here real
quick
uh it's about 47 seconds long listen to
this this is in tennessee i understand
that that a
uh someone who has committed a rape
would not be able to
uh sue if an abortion would take place
would a family member of said rapist be
able to sue would they have standing
down from 21. thank you if it is the
parents siblings
aunts and uncles grandparents then yes
uh same question then for incest as well
thank you yes
so if i am raped and choose to have an
abortion and my rapist has 10 siblings
is there anything to preclude all of
them and their spouses
um bringing a lawsuit for 20 000 each
down from twenty one i'm not sure their
spouses are included in that list but uh
no
did you hear that did you hear what he
did he just and he's like yeah sure why
not [ __ ] it why not
why not i like i i like how
just nonchalant
just the question is like oh could all
of them
bring you know each family member bring
20 000. so like could this woman be sued
for 200 000 and he goes well i don't
know if spouses are included right yeah
that's a little that's a little that's a
great thing he's like i don't know if
spouses are included but yeah mm-hmm and
yeah what the [ __ ] are you talking about
what world are we living in
where
this is
is the normal like what what the [ __ ] is
happening where we have to punish the
the victim
again mentally physically and then say
hey while you're still recovering and
dealing with that trauma we're also
gonna [ __ ] you over financially so uh
yeah you're gonna have to deal with this
it's gonna go on your record uh
and then uh it's not only just one like
party as a whole to be like the family
could sue you it's each individual
[ __ ] person in that [ __ ] family
like
what
who who thought of this like who thought
like hey you know what
you know what would be a great idea yeah
right she'll be the victim yeah exactly
well and not only suing the victim but
make sure all the siblings of the rapist
can actually see the victim that would
be a cool thing to do that that sounds
like a brilliant idea maybe we should do
that
it really is it really is uh
i i don't even know if they see the
fascism in it like if they're if they're
so blinded by their own
uh by their own ideology that they can't
see the fascism in it but you know it is
what it is speaking of fascist um
there's been a lot of news lately uh
updates with uh uh enrique
tario uh stuart rhodes and some others
uh that are associated the oath keepers
we actually had the privilege of talking
to dakota adams again we recorded the
interview uh on monday uh and actually
during during the time of which uh some
news broke um yeah so you're gonna get
to see that in the interview of course
we know that news now but you posted um
this video about the breaking news i
want to show it here uh let's see let's
pull it up here you said uh remember
that one time
remember that one time enrique tario
proud boys stewart rhodes oath keepers
and kelly sareer oath keepers and bianca
uh garcia latinos for trump met in a
parking lot on january 5th so tell us
about this clip that you found and then
i'll and then i'll play it right so
in in the the court docs there's a
reference which we we talked about uh in
this interview
that
there was a documentary film crew
that was recording for i don't you know
i gotta give him props like i guess if
you're gonna go out
and commit an act of sedition
uh you might as well record it right and
you might as well say yeah we did it
um
well i mean why wouldn't why wouldn't
they do the reality tv show thing like
that right
you're like hey you know we're going to
shop this around we're going to maybe
see if e news is interested you know the
kardashians like jesus but basically but
think about this this is january 5th
they still think donald they're going to
make donald trump the king here right
and they think they're going to make him
king so why wouldn't they think
if we're going to create this world
where donald trump can protect us well
this is going to be gold
this is going to be going to show how we
made him king
it's anyone's game at this point like
that's what i'm seeing from them they're
like hey you know what okay let's all
secretly so here's the thing enrique
tario had just been
he had just gotten in trouble for
burning the flag uh for the the black
lives matter flight he pulled it out he
pulled the he pulled this banner off a
church which was their private property
exactly and they burned them in the
street right that's what he gets in
trouble for and they're like hey listen
you gotta get the [ __ ] out of dc and
then he's like okay okay okay
doesn't leave
when and then instead
he meets all of these other people as
well as other uh uh oath keepers in this
garage
to plan
something like there's a whole thing and
it's revealed in the court documents of
things that were said you know messages
that were sent
uh and uh like a new kind of revelation
of like what exactly was planned
beforehand despite the fact that
everyone's like there was no there it
was just a bunch of tourists they were
you know yeah sure things kind of got
out of hand whatever uh no what really
was is they were planning this and they
documented this they literally had a
film crew for for whether it was a news
or was an actual independent documentary
crew
same thing happened with roger stone
you find out that there's this
i forget the title the film i think it's
uh
yeah
roger uh i know what you're talking
about yeah right it was the one that was
highlighted in the washington post and
which we have a screenshot of um from
that film which is uh his his uh his
signal messages
but again it's like these these guys are
so
narcissistic
and egotistical
and
uh and obsessed with the fact that they
are right and no one else is right
because they're going to be the ones who
are successful to overthrow the
government and keep donald trump as
president and do anything they want
and so then you look at this and they're
like hey you know what we need this one
for the history books because we're
going to show our kids how we [ __ ]
did it right and then now it's like yeah
yeah the department of justice is like
you did it yeah they're literally just
like going through like you guys want to
binge watch this [ __ ] this is crazy so
let's let's watch the clip it's only 22
seconds here and then and then we'll get
to the interview uh where we asked
dakota not just about uh stuart um uh
rhodes uh little minion uh john is
joshua or john it's joshua james right
joshua joshua james who played uh guilty
to seditious conspiracy he's the oath
keeper that recently pled guilty but
also about um we asked him about
enrique's uh little uh nip slip on uh
when they uh arrest him and then also
about another oath keeper who has come
out against steroids but let's watch
this clip here real quick
stewart pleasure
pleasure
he's joined by stuart rhodes founder of
the oath keepers militia
several of his members have also been
arrested and prosecutors allege some
oath keepers may have been planning the
attack as early as november
rhodes himself has not been arrested so
this is before stewart rhodes was
arrested
and and the the thing here about this
whole thing is that and we kind of asked
dakota about this and he actually tries
to give his uh intake on this our input
in this it it really does seem like it
wasn't just one group committing this
conspiracy like they were trying to get
as many people in on this conspiracy as
they possibly could so that way
they it wouldn't fail like there was all
these fail-safes like if every because
cause we've talked to tasha adams uh
stuart rhodes estranged wife and dakota
before and they have said that stewart
rhodes really did not like the proud
boys right yeah not not necessarily that
they were enemies but they did not like
each other um there was a lot of uh
rifts between a lot of these militia
groups um and and that's been the
history of militia groups right frankly
um and and if you go back and watch if
you subscribe to the youtube channel you
can go back and watch uh the extended uh
long version of us interviewing tasha
and dakota at the same time we talk
about how stuart uh got his eye patch
but we also talk about the evolution of
the oath keepers and believe it or not
stuart rhodes at one point was trying to
run out white nationalists out of his
group because he didn't want white
nationalists in his group but then that
all changed because of recruiting became
so easy once trump came to office so
um
so let's let's play the interview
it's i think it's about 50 minutes here
so we're gonna play the interview and
then on the other side of the interview
we'll come back we'll give some more
thoughts on it
uh so stick around the interview with
dakota adams on the updates of the oath
keepers right after these messages
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny
we know what you would do you'd reach
out and give that true american a hand
now here's your chance for only 50
dollars a day you can help us help those
true americans recover from biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those trump supporters and this is that
moment
send your donation via venmo to the real
president donald j trump
it's only fifty dollars a day
recurring and it means you'll get these
trump supporters the critical help they
so desperately need to survive under
this false regime
please donate now because those trump
supporters you just saw
can't wait another
moment catch tony's twitch stream the
[ __ ] list roundup at twitch.tv
slash the tony michaels
we're back to the king of brilliant this
is the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome back to the show thanks for
hanging with us at the break uh we have
a special guest with us here today
dakota adams he's been here before
dakota how are you
doing just fine i'm feeling very slick
today good yeah you look he looks like
look yeah look suave yeah yeah nice
jacket too nice jacket yep i came in uh
accidentally dressed like i'm at the
comic book store and i have a lot of
opinions about woke marvel that i want
to share with you
my costume for the day well i i wish we
could talk about
i had questions about woke marvel or
woke disney but those are not the
questions i have for you today i have a
couple subjects that i've been wanting
to ask you about over the last few weeks
um the first off i want to ask you about
jason von tattenhoven um he was a he was
he used to be an oath keeper he's been
doing some interviews lately trying to
distance himself from the oath keepers
now you know jason correct yes uh we
hung out with him quite a bit he was out
keepers a main pr guy
for i believe two years
uh lived in our town uh worked closely
with stuart over at our house all the
time and on and we're both in local
emergency services he was on search and
rescue
so i got to know him pretty well his
split with the oath keepers i want to
ask about that but first off
do you think we're going to see more and
more uh
prior oath keepers or you know veteran
oath keepers as it were distance
themselves from this group as more and
more about this seditious conspiracy
comes out and starts to play out with
some of the conviction and not not just
the indictments but also some of the
plea deals that have been had do you
think that's going to happen more and
more
i think it's going to happen some more
but it's not going to be a huge number
because a large number of the people
that are not okay with the direction of
the oath keepers went they split well in
the past a lot of the people that would
have been coming out as ex-health
keepers or especially had splinter
groups
um think talking more like people who
split her away and disavow health
keepers
during the ferguson riots
and afterwards when the militia aspect
started to become more pronounced
so there's going to be some people who
held on for a while
and are now disavowing oath keepers
but this but most of people just about
oath keepers they long since did that
and a bunch of them
are still not going to be friendly with
what they perceive as
uh leftist or
uh
mainstream aligned media and won't be
speaking with anybody except like
revolver anywhere right right
so why do you think the the sudden
change you said he was the pr guy so he
was in there for two years like so why
do you think the sudden change of heart
or like uh
the the reinventing or whatever you want
to call it um why do you think like now
all of a sudden well from looking at his
twitter he's been trying to build a
different life outside of oath keepers
for a while and i genuinely hope it goes
well for him because aside from
sticking up for stewart
in the past
it never really
done anything wrong aside from being
involved in oath keepers when it looked
more like a legitimate organization
but i think now that oath keepers is a
big thing he's basically just trying to
get his name out there
okay so you think he might be
capitalizing off the uh
the oath keepers being in the news and
he was a former member the pr guy
because apparently um there's a story
that that stuart actually lived on this
guy's couch for a while yes he lived in
it he lived in a basement room
in this guy's house and might have been
instrumental in getting this guy
actually evicted
from his house in eureka because they
trashed it so thoroughly and from what i
understood a big part of that was the
squalor that stewart lives in habitually
it was so bad that
it pushed
their landlord into becoming an early
adopter of airbnb
for our area anyway yeah because it was
just it would that was the final straw
for long-term renters
was having to
almost renovate the house after they
were gone
and from my personal experience with
stuart if it wasn't mostly him he was at
least a
very contributing factor
to the house being completely trashed so
so was this kind of the split between
stuart and and jason then i mean was
that where it kind of happened
because yeah because the last i know
that
he and tattenhoeven were
on speaking terms and hanging out was
when stewart was living in their house
up until
they got evicted now they weren't just
on speaking terms uh tattenhoven
actually um
vouched for stuart apparently in some of
the
the ongoing court proceedings against
stewart and your family is that is that
right yes he showed up to a hearing
as a character witness for stuart the
uh sitting in the waiting room with him
was tremendously awkward and at least
hit him and one of stuart's little
bodyguard dudes
just trying to make small talk about
wildland fire and how long ago was that
2018 that would have been later on in
2018. so at this point we're looking at
uh almost almost four years now that
that was that he's been quote unquote
rebuilding his reputation from some of
those points where he was actually
helping stuart so yeah he's only been
doing interviews relatively recently i
believe talking about atoning for his
part in oath keepers but the uh the time
to speak up and start speaking up was a
while ago right
but now because stuart's in the news and
there's press around oath oathkeepers at
january 6th and
you know it's an opportune time to you
know atone for your sins you know not to
say that maybe he maybe he is genuine
maybe he is yeah maybe you're your
genuine i don't want to say too much bad
about him because going against
even with stewart indicted going against
a group like goat keepers can right
and be scary and maybe he just wanted to
be forgotten about
until it became clear that oath keepers
was not going away right in the news
cycle i'm
trying very hard not to hold a personal
grudge well i i i did see
uh i didn't mean to step on either i did
see that him and tasha your mother um
actually had a cordial back and forth on
twitter um about some of the things that
were said and you know i don't i don't
know if there was a conclusion or uh
resolution to that but it is it is at
some point good to see that he's willing
to admit some of the wrongs that he
possibly did and defended for for maybe
quite some time so yeah i mean i think
that was the extent of their contact
you would have to be uh you have to ask
tasha for more details about that all
right because that's
basically all that i know but that was
on
i had to hunt around on twitter to find
that conversation i think he actually
started another twitter account and
abandoned that one
people started their conversation that
he knew he was talking to her because
they started with uh her asking him if
he would trust stewart along with his
children
and he said no
right well and it was in like a thread
because i i saw it it was in like a
thread of maybe an interview that he had
done or something um
a thread for another news article and
then right on his account he's got links
to interview interviews
he chimed in the comments talking and
then
that popped up on my mom's twitter radar
now there is more oath keepers in the
news um we have seen that joshua james
um who is one of the i think the
original 11 that were indicted on uh
seditious conspiracy with stuart um who
apparently and i know you'll probably
tell us more about this that you've read
um who it seems like he was almost like
roger stone's personal bodyguard that
day was with him the entire day during
january 6. um but you don't know joshua
james um but tell us what you do what
tell us what you do know about maybe the
oath keepers lending him as a bodyguard
to someone who may have needed
protection that day how that works why
why the oath keepers would do that and
then tell us too because it seems like
there's a chain of command thing going
on where he's standing he's next to
roger
our last interview you talked about uh
stuart being uh over that had the
command over the qrf so tell us about
how some of that works and if it's even
relevant in this case
i think it's extremely relevant and i
think we're going to see seeing more
weird connections to roger stone
emerging as time goes on i honestly the
uh
the screen capture or the the picture
that was taken during that documentary
that showed uh
stuart rhodes in roger stones frequently
contacted on his telegram contacts
you're talking about where it showed his
his telephone screen yes that might have
been it might have been signal app i
can't remember which one it was but it
was uh i expected another layer of
abstraction i expected it
to be someone like joshua james who was
relaying
information from roger stone and back
and forth to stuart if they were in
direct contact with each other i didn't
expect them to be just talking on the
phone right well apparently they
kept it a little bit simpler than i
thought they would have well and it
seems like roger stone is the only one
layer between maybe stuart rhodes or
whoever whomever and donald trump
because we know we know from prior past
that roger stone and donald trump have
talked about texting each other and
talking on the phone personally on their
personal cell phone so now i don't know
if it was that day
one could only suspect that rogers
one could only suspect that roger stone
probably has donald trump's phone number
rather he text him and call him maybe
that's maybe that's something that
january 6 select committee and the
department of justice would be
interested in um
also i i think that's probably fair to
say so yeah in their respective that the
oath keepers because here's the thing
it seemed originally that the proud boys
and i'm going to talk a little more
about the brown boys here in a minute
but it seemed like originally the proud
boys were the ones that were going to
protect rogers stone which in our
interview where you and your mom tasha
were you guys kind of said there's a
riff between oath keepers and uh proud
boys possibly
but if if nothing else or rift that
exists inside the head of stuart rhodes
which means that it exists
as far as healthcare is concerned
because stewart's delusions
direct oath keepers right right
well so so
do you think there's any significance in
roger stone bailing
on the proud boys
um
uh detail and going with joshua james as
it were do you think there's anything
significant about that that he would
choose
to go with oath keepers maybe to have i
mean it seemed like he had a direct line
with stewart but maybe to have that
extra contact point i don't know with
the qrf maybe um i
genuinely couldn't guess i have a
feeling that whatever happened that
caused that last minute switch
is weirder
than
any of us would guess at
trying to figure out what happened
behind the scenes there because the
inside of oath keepers operations
chaotic
always always chaotic always a mess
but something stuart really liked to do
was get his guys in there as security
detail for important people is always
offering oath keepers up a security
detail
for important people he had the world's
worst instagram selfie
um escorting women
into the trump ball a stuart stewart was
escorting them yes after does the photo
still exist somewhere you think oh i
think it does it's like
he looks it looks like
it looks like a uh self-portrait of mr
potato head
it's like one quarter of his face
[Laughter]
on like a 2009 flip phone or a
blackberry
oh in 2016. and he posted it he posted
he posted that saying this i we're
escorting
young lady grateful young ladies or
something like that into the maga ball
because they were where was this was
this in dc or
i think this this was the maga ball in
dc right after the election
oh okay so that so this was this was
before the insurrection maybe maybe this
one there was uh there was contact to
plan to plan who knows yeah i think this
might have been
the origin point for whoever he had
personal contact with
that was getting him in better and
better with
the trump with the trump people because
that was the first
like before that stewart wasn't getting
invited to cpac or any of this [ __ ]
right
well because he kind of had a riff he
had kind of had a riff with trump right
like he he wrote kind of a manifesto
that said [ __ ] trump kind of thing right
i mean he was eventually critical
critical of trump in this case of the
horrible procrastination worked in his
favor because he never actually wrote
his open letter to donald trump
schooling among the constitution he just
talked about it a bunch
and it never progressed beyond the draft
stage which made it easier for him to
completely pivot to being
a hardcore
trump fanboy later on when that became
more personally convenient
and the fear of hillary the deep
seated fear of hillary clinton being
elected took hold
and and this all stems and we've talked
about this before this all stems from
his fear delusion it may be delusion it
may be reality that that the department
of justice would come after him or the
oath keepers for events that happened uh
during the bundy ranch event is that
correct yes that is absolutely my read
of it because oathkeepers was more
involved
better organized
than
many of the people
especially uh
like
cellular militia group leadership
or charge for their involvement in bundy
ranch
i see i see well i know i know we have
some uh speaking of proud boys in the
rift and um that sort of thing the other
piece of news that we have um
is uh
gabe's favorite favorite proud boy uh
enrique tario i'm gonna kind of let gabe
asking questions because i know i know
tario is uh gabe's done a few videos on
here and and
he's one of gabe's uh favorite pro boys
so i'll let him ask but but to to give
set the scene here uh he was he was
arrested which is a hilarious video by
the way he was arrested and indicted
also
on uh seditious uh conspiracy charges
now
it seems kind of funny that it would be
proud boys and oath keepers to groups
that may or may not be associated but
gabe uh take it away on any questions
you have about proud boys and eureka
enrique enrique i think is a very
interesting story right he's afro-cuban
he's
leader of the proud boys
i know that there's a rift within that
team of like who's really the leader now
you know kind of thing you know he
the thing that took him to jail for five
months where he complained about the
conditions the horrible dc conditions uh
was because he burned uh uh it was a
black lives matter flag and that's where
he got busted yeah didn't he tear it off
didn't he tear it off a church tear it
up and then they brought the church and
burned it like of all the things that
he's probably been associated with that
was the thing that got him in trouble
blatantly doing it and caught himself
caught himself in 4k and so then
obviously most recently uh
nobody nobody knew right not even his
lawyer had a heads up of of them coming
to arrest him right he get he comes out
at least he had some boxers on
uh we had enrique tario full nips
uh ready to go and get arrested
um but yeah i just think like just this
just just the
the the concept of enrique tario as the
leader of the proud boys is one i think
fascinating in and of itself
but also you know you talked about this
relationship or rather this
uh
fantasy like rift maybe was was in his
was in stuart's mind or not but like
jealousy that right uh
gavin mcginnis and other people
associated with the proud boys get top
billing over him and events
jealousy that trump would give shout
outs to the proud boys
or that important political figures
would give shout outs to the proud boys
and he wouldn't that they got more media
attention
just endless endless jealousy yeah
why do you why do you think trump would
shout them out more sorry give it to me
more publicly visible
because uh trump watches cable news
if you want if you want to know why
trump is talking about a particular
thing it's because it was featured on
fox news that is
the most
likely answer to any given question for
why is trump talking about windmills
when somebody asks him about ukraine
it's because he thought on kennedy that
night and that's the only thing in his
head right right which i the other thing
too i mean like he also did give a shout
out during the debates right and it was
like you know will you denounce uh this
group and he's like stand back and stand
by and everyone's like
you know and everyone proud boys and
probably others affiliated maybe those
keepers took it as a signal to
themselves to be like great we are
locked and loaded ready to go whenever
he gives us a signal and spam the
standby the standby signal that fueled a
whole bunch of people
and i think that was very deliberate and
it's very smart it does that the thing
that we keep talking about when we
discuss trump and right-wing populism
and the alt-right and this uh fascist
movement to take control of america
using
like channels like fox news to signal
boost
is the creation of a set of can the
creation
of a mindset for mob violence or
political violence to be triggered by
keywords that give the people issuing
the order plausible deniability
right right it's very much like
like a sikkim type approach like he has
him ready and he'll you know feed him
little treats here and there and then he
you know whenever he feels like he needs
to get the signal or whenever they feel
like they've interpreted that signal
whatever it might be then they're ready
to they're ready to pounce on on
whatever protect attack
you know whatever whatever that uh
whatever that that disgusting world that
trump has made they you know they feel
like they're validated and they can go
forward with it but i think the other
thing too is
on
uh for with the proud boys is the fact
that like enrique tario is a snitch i
mean like let's just call what it is
right the guy has a record working with
federal and state law enforcement back
in 2013 2014 he has a history so to say
that he won't turn on anyone else to
to lessen his sentence or to get out of
whatever a charges or or time he's
looking at like
oh 100 percent you know like
want to see
always
will and
i'm this would need to be double checked
because i'm not 100 certain i believe
there is footage of stuart rhodes and
tario meeting in a parking garage
somewhere
in dc on the day of the six so there's
like cctv
don't you have a video game of
game has a video uh that he made it's
satire it's satire but it literally is
guys meeting in a parking garage
it's fbi it's fbi he's setting out for a
drug bust
and uh
yeah it's just enrique tario you know
trying to clean the streets off from
uh from non-white people he wants only
white people and then only to realize
that he himself is not white
it's the same realization candace owens
is going to have some day
oh wait
she's in the news today but yeah maybe
couple things couple things i want to go
over here because uh you said a couple
names uh gavin mcginnis because we've
been back and forth with who's the
leader of the proud boys but he's he's
kind of the the uh the originator right
yeah he's the originator and then he
lost it all he was in the first wave of
loud
in your face this is back when they were
calling themselves like the alt-right
right and there was when they were
calling this was the alt-right but also
insisting that the alt-right wasn't
racist right uh hot [ __ ] and he was uh
he got his claim to fame was uh
compilations of him just uh
like talking about his college hookups
in the worst way possible
while supposedly debating
supposedly debating a feminist and like
going on joe rogan and being just like
so graphic and weird that it like gave
joe rogan visible pause
and he got um he got famous
as a personality
for that it was the celebration
a locker room talk
worldwide talk let's bring this [ __ ]
into the open we're going to say the
quiet part so [ __ ] loud you won't be
able to not hear it he's also famous for
some other things right yeah well
very toxic uh
he was just a little bit too
of much of an early adopter for his own
good because he was still very much
in the
stage of right-wing populism
where you still pretend to be
libertarian or pretend to be centrist or
maybe you are just a little bit and it's
it's all about uh trashing
still about trashing leftism and
feminism and everything else that your
reactionary audience might find icky or
think is funny just because it's
offensive
like that's that's like the love at the
base level of uh this is hilarious
because it's offensive a dime out about
it
but he still had the reflexive urge to
do kind of centrist hedging
in that
and he got to admire
the follow-through
of trying to go all the way with both of
those of being as graphic and offensive
and loud and in your face as possible
while insisting that you're not uh
homophobic or racist
and this ended up with
i don't want to say following it to us
logical conclusion that's not quite the
right word but the end result was he
decided would be a good idea
to
shove a dildo up his ass on a live
stream to prove that he doesn't hate gay
people well he got us he owned the
rights right
[Laughter]
definitely owned them
surprise surprise uh
his audience he might have been already
slipping from the public eye at that
point so it's also a little bit of a
look at me thing but his audience wasn't
really down with that and that kind of
tilt
his dominance of
the right-wing manosphere and he slid
into obscurity i haven't heard
of anything gavin mcinnes is doing in
like four years right so it no longer
was he the mantle of macho machismo at
that point what was that before or after
charlottesville because i know i know
that for charlotte charlottesville was
uh because charlottesville kind of put
the uh dagger in the quote-unquote
alt-right uh when they were calling it
that before they rebranded the to
something different that was when uh
vanguard america was pretending to not
be neo-nazis right right that's right
the all-right was pretending not to be
racist and then
the mask kind of fell away
right right when they had that event
right they still had their shields but
they got new uh uh logos what's what's
that what's the group called now what do
they call it patriot front yeah patrick
they put up uh posters that have razor
blades embedded in the back so you cut
yourself if you take them down
they try to co-op other uh right-wing
group marches like they showed up and
crashed
uh yeah
yeah they'll go to march for pro lifers
and they they run them the [ __ ] off
because they know they're nazis and
they're like yeah you're making us look
like nazis we can't look like not i mean
we are nazis but we can't look like
nazis we can't probably look like nazis
well
um which is probably a breeding ground
also for like this um
this group called adam waffen which is
uh they're outright nazis like they
admit they're nazis um i think out of
walkman is a successor organization to
some very old
white supremacist groups like the one my
uh father's family married into like old
school
aryan nation types right right right
well and there's even some groups that
are starting some communities i think in
idaho and some other places um that are
looking for right-wing places where
neo-nazis used to be they ran them off
and now the right wings kind of going
back to those to those kind of
fell out of favor and out of the public
eye and went i would call it more
dormancy
than anything and uh under under the
rocks as it were kind of yeah right now
they're scurrying into the daylight but
they're also perceiving because fascism
like
your ideology is that you're always
under threat by some
massively powerful enemy that could be
easily defeated if you just pull the
pull it together and they're they're
still getting they're still in the uh
waiting for the black helicopters
mindset
and so
like a lot of times idaho
gets glanced over as a small as like a
militia stronghold at a right-wing
stronghold i know keepers had a very
heavy idaho presence there were a lot of
very well organized state chapters down
there
and as ever
like even with charlottesville if i
am not remembering wrong that was a
second amendment protest that was
well originally it was because of the
statute coming down they wanted to pull
oh no you are you're right that was a
completely different thing that was a
confederate
it was the people who love lincoln but
hate lincoln who fly the american flag
but i think lincoln is a great president
it's it's really weird [ __ ] the thin
blanket of being pro-america and the
party of lincoln over
desperately wanted the confederacy back
so yes that's where you unite the right
that was unite the right and all that
that so yeah i was thinking of something
completely different but uh no what i
was thinking of was the
which state capital i'm a little bit
burnt out today i've inhaled too many
cat pee fumes doing demolition trailer
right before i can that's what the
jacket's about too right yeah that's for
the jack
into the least blue collar thing that i
own to distance myself from the smell
[Laughter]
um whichever state capital it was where
they had the massive pro second
amendment march and that was the one
where the base was going to show up and
do a drive-by shooting in blackface and
they got popped by the fbi
i i is this michigan
because i know there's i know there's
big right-wing uh movements in michigan
yeah there was the there was the
michigan state capital right the
dozens of second amendment rights right
and the other the other thing too is
they they they had the plot the right
wingers had the plot to kidnap the
governor and uh there's been there's
been a lot of uh
several of those most of them sovereign
citizens right because there's a lot of
right-wing militia in michigan right i
mean that's there's a there's a big
brood of them there if you i feel like
michigan should redo their uh their like
travel psa where it's like pure michigan
you know it's like pure
michigan
no no it's pure it's like pure white
maybe right right like
well but i mean but i mean maybe that's
maybe that's why the piano yeah yeah it
was true like it was attractive
you're like oh pure well hey that that
was right up our alley well even going
back to the uh like in the 90s like uh
like books like uh wesley rolls uh
patriots which is the most god-awful
militia fiction you will ever read they
refer to michigan as militia because
it's a hotbed of resistance against the
new world order and the post-collapse
and all this [ __ ] so that's been true
for a long time right right but the
general trend is that whenever there is
a surge
in
standard right-wing activity
neo-nazis will show up and try to co-opt
it and try to recruit
and infiltrate and gain influence there
was a concerted effort organized on
stormfront to infiltrate oath keepers
chapters and try to bring them around to
being racially aware there are neo-nazis
that crash
uh
nominally non-racist militia events
and it was something uh
when i was a kid
militia leaders were very concerned
about was the attempt
by nazis
to gain control of the militia movement
or at least make it look to the outside
like they were gaining control because
that would create a feedback loop but i
guess in the face of
crt
um that's spared abandoned and nobody's
trying nobody's trying to keep the
camel's nose out from underneath the
tent anymore yeah it's uh long since
overweight and that's where
uh you get tons of white supremacists
moving to
um
inside the movement fairly well-known
militia stronghold areas like idaho and
the more nazis move to idaho
the more it gets social media buzz as
the nazi place the more nazis are going
to move there which you know might be
nice to have them all concentrated but
you also don't want them to become a
majority in any one place right right
lots of land and little diversity right
right well lots of nazis anywhere is
kind of scary to me so speaking of nazis
and uh groups of nazis let's let's go
right back because i wanna i wanna touch
on a few points ontario uh here because
it seems significant uh like gabe said
earlier that there was no leaks from the
doj about his arrest which i think is
significant and i'm gonna ask a question
here uh also i think uh the nips the nip
the nip video was planned i believe that
was planned not just by the doj but
possibly by intario himself and the
reason why i think that and i'll tell
you here in a minute uh but i believe it
has to do with him being a snitch and
then also he wasn't at january 6 which i
think is significant so first off the no
leaks um i think that's significant in
that that doj is keeping tight lips on
any indictments that may be coming with
this conspiracy rather it be with those
keepers rather be with roger stone
rather be with proud boys especially
when we see ryder stone having ties to
not only uh this uh joshua james
character but also with the proud boys i
believe that that those tight lips and
roger stone not being indicted is very
very very significant um to the nips
thing
i think it should be tight tight lips
hard nips
that is perfect that is perfect i think
enrique dario has a new nickname tight
lips no no he would be loose lips hard
nips
tight lips loose lips and hard nips so
here's my take on the the nips video is
because enrico tario knows how this uh
being an informant works and a lot of
times when you're an informant you get
indicted you get formally indicted and
the indictment is actually to show
everyone around you that hey this person
may now be talking but also you want to
make it look like that that person may
not be cooperating as much as everyone
thinks like they want to create this
obscurity so in my mind in my mind the
video of him coming out and then making
a fool of him and then indicting him but
maybe he is already talking uh do you
think there's significance in that or is
that just some kind of thing that i'm
making up in my head
i genuinely don't know it could be
reading just a bit much into it because
in my personal experience with
likely informants
that have been at
like
weird dudes that have been
at the epicenter of everything that's
ever gone wrong for the militia movement
and then disappeared immediately and got
like new multi-million dollar houses in
wyoming by the time anyone drops them
down
nothing ever happens to them
like there were guys that were
on the interstellar bundy's inner circle
at bundy ranch at malheur who were
there's one dude in particular who
was at bounty ranch and malheur
who was
claimed to be an army ranger but was
actually army intelligence and possibly
a cia contractor
and his entire record had been
fabricated and he was deeply involved
and was never charged and just
disappeared off the map there's
been plenty of people around stuart
who would try to like
probe like people that i knew into weird
conversations with leading questions
like what are you going to do
specifically
if uh you can write it down can you
write it down for me on the phone what
are you going to do if there's a tank
rolling down your street and they're
confiscating guns what's your plan
specifically in that hypothetical
scenario and everybody's just like
is this is this is this what is some of
the delusion and uh that stewart
developed you think uh throughout the
years and maybe maybe uh
part of that makes him act the way he
acts you think i mean where he sees some
of this stuff happening and he hears
this stuff
yeah i think it definitely feeds into it
and i mean just like uh
there is an element of truth to
every single paranoid militia delusion
just like uh
they can't it's like chemtrails
conspiracy theory has its origins in the
very very real operation sea spray
during the cold war there is that
element of truth and the element of
truth is that they're if you're in the
mueller movement there are informants
everywhere but a lot of those informants
are like drowning men in a shipwreck and
they're just trying to grab at anything
they can and that's where
i'm
seeing like some potential similarities
between enrique tario
and uh
stuart is
i think stuart might have
been
compromised and been informing at some
point
but he's always trying to get clear
right that's my personal read so i don't
know if that arrest video of
tario was faked or right aged right so
some news here uh this was as of two
hours ago okay um
uh scott mcfarlane i said alert in
motion uh seeking pre-trial jail of
enrique tario and capital riot
conspiracy case feds allege not only did
taro and stuart rhodes meet on january
5th
but
documentary film crew was present in the
garage and at one point picked up audio
of a person referencing the capitol but
it looks like prosecutors also alleged
that tario posted on social media 20
minutes after accused proud boy dominic
pizzola smashed open capital window on
january 6
saying after i finish watching this i'll
make a statement about my arrest but for
now i'm enjoying the show
do what must be done
uh there's more obviously more inside of
this uh
this these trial documents but uh
i mean you know to go back to what you
were you were saying dakota yes they did
in fact meet because it is in fact on
these court documents
yeah so yeah but january 5th
yeah they they met up they were in the
garage and now it looks like they have
audio recording of at least
part of this part of a conversation
about the capital you know that's pretty
significant too having considered what i
said earlier about that tario was not at
january 6. he was not in the city of dc
on january 6. so my assumption is in
that story that is breaking and it's
just an assumption here that they
probably met outside the city of dc
somewhere else the day before
um to do whatever talking or planning
that they were oh this was in downtown
d.c so they so he was indeed because
yeah he said wasn't tario not allowed in
dc because of the burning thing right so
tario was released at approximately 5
p.m on january 5th after having been in
order to leave the district of columbia
tario did not immediately comply with
the order instead he traveled to an
underground parking garage located in
downtown washington d.c where for
approximately 30 minutes he met with a
group of individuals that included elmer
stewart rhodes iii the founder and
leader of the oath keepers a documentary
film crew was present in the garage and
at one point picked up audio that i just
referenced while in the parking garage
tario uh told another individual that he
had cleared all the messages on his
phone before he was arrested tario
further stated no one would be able to
get into his phone because there were no
uh because there were two steps to get
into it two and then two factor out yeah
two factor authentication can't break
two-factor authentication
[Laughter]
well he is a [ __ ] he is a [ __ ] and it
says thereafter tario left the district
of columbia and traveled to baltimore
maryland that evening tario used the
phones of associates to make a number of
phone calls and to log back into his
encrypted messaging accounts after
having regained access to his accounts
tario assured his men that his phones
had not been compromised and taro was
subsequently added back into both the
mosd leaders group and the new mosd
members what does that mosd stand for
real quick mosd stands for ministry of
self-defense
according to these uh to this court doc
like everything is laid out in this
court document it's 21 pages of the the
the tension
uh memorandum but we'll try to link to
it too uh yeah yeah and in here it says
you know december 19th is when the plans
were announced to protest dc for the
certification and then beginning in late
december 2020 tario created a new
chapter for the proud boys referred to
as the ministry of self-defense or mosd
he described the mosd as a national
rally planning chapter that would
include only hand selected members tario
and the other mosd leaders imposed a
command and control structure on this
new chapter tario identified the mosd
leaders and organized them into
operational council and marketing
council and then here's the thing on
january 6th his men the leaders and
members of the mosd were on the front of
the crowd who unlawfully breached the
capital grounds and overran police lines
meant to protect the capital on his
occupants so
does that answer your question to code
on the mom
that's uh pretty important okay well
tell us the importance real quick before
we just just that uh
there was a just
there was a special chat room set aside
for
the
central planning of
of rallies and that was operating as a
cover for
most likely the planning of the
breaching of the capital and what's
starting to
emerge here is
it kind of looks to me like oath keepers
and proud boys were given parallel
missions is that like as like as a like
a redundancy measure if one failed the
other could continue yes and that's
where you have uh the proud boys are the
experienced street brawler guys were
expected to be at the forefront
of any attack they're the ones who get
the crowd into the building to create
chaos and then of course you have the
stack
that's going in and looking for the
offices of certain politicians so that
stat going interior had a mission and
then the qrf on the outside was going to
be activated as soon as there was cover
for bringing weapons into dc and going
live fire
so at every so
because in order for the entire plan to
go off once there is an antifa there to
brawl with
somebody has to smash open the capital
doors somebody has to break open the
windows
and get people inside to create chaos
for other groups to operate in and that
is where proud boys would have had a lot
more street brawling experience
than oath keepers because oathkeepers
always hangs back that's why they didn't
get top billing when the proud boys did
they got a little bit of a cold sorry if
i'm doing going a little bit friend
rusher audio on the audio
no it's okay but uh
it's like oath keepers is always hanging
back in the background with a shitload
of guns and riot gear super ready to go
but never in the mix because that's
stewart rhodes that's his monosapparandi
he's the big tough guy he's gonna get it
done but he never gets
where he can get punched right oh yeah
he's just
just further like far enough away where
if someone were to punch you would be
out of line
yeah yeah just a little bit back wearing
all the [ __ ]
but like
ready to go
for being the super for being a [ __ ]
survival a superhero
so in other words so in other words
we're talking about cosplay here yes
but
uh
i mean the uh
the sa will cosplayers until hitler
power
the assets were the greatest cosplayers
in history
until they were put in charge of
genocide and did a bang-up job
so i feel like when people say uh
cosplay i was like talking about patriot
front like yeah like
by the standards of like historical
reenactment people
and like hema people and [ __ ] uh
like
patriot front or vanguard america's
little shield walls amateurish and
ridiculous and their training videos are
[ __ ] ridiculous but they are training
and organizing and that's very very bad
um right a bunch of both keepers might
look ridiculous fully kitted out in
their tactical gear but they're showing
up
as
an organized group that's done training
to go do something which is extremely
bad and as ridiculous as it might seem
it'd be a huge mistake
to discount it just because it looks
silly well i think i agree with you and
i'd love to i'd love to talk to you more
about the essay and the ss because a lot
of people don't know the difference and
they don't know that the essay was the
unsuccessful group that hitler uh they
had to have tried to have a violent take
over the government and that's why he
went to prison and then he ended up when
he took over the government those were
the first he killed was the essay those
are the first murders those are that was
the leadership that were
around on a relatively equal footing
with hitler when he was beginning his
movement that is where there actually
was
factually for a little bit of time ace
actually socialist wing
of the nazi party that was uh or at
least a left-leaning wing of the nazi
party i believe in some socialism that
was strasserism and those are the first
people to die because it's always
the brown shirts that were it was like
like when somebody makes it big and as
an athlete or as a musician and suddenly
they're making the big bucks
their first wife who stuck with them
during the ramen noodle years
gets ditched for a trophy wife
immediately that's how dictators treat
their supporters
i like the ramen noodle years i like the
unwashed mob
of hardcore political brawlers and
supporters that see you into power
become a liability once you're there
especially the leadership so you cut off
everything you can't use
and you fold the survivors into the new
group that is
better and classier and more stiffed up
and they got hugo boss uniforms they
think you're god
and they're 100 on board and undyingly
loyal well i let's let's try to keep
these fools in the ramen noodle years
let's try to keep them there let's try
not to advance them at all dakota thank
you for joining us i appreciate come
back anytime we want to keep talking you
as the the news develops as it just did
right here on here uh thank you very
much make sure to follow make sure to
follow dakota on twitter and uh follow
his mom go to their website also uh look
at some of the books um i i've been
meaning to read the the first i i
believe it's like the first
uh i read the first draft but i think
she has another piece that she's put on
the website yeah she's got an outtake
that doesn't really fit in well with the
flow of the story that's just a little
bit about uh so it's like a short story
in other words yeah being uh snuck into
um
a law firm
to cover for to cover for stuart in the
most ridiculous mundane way possible
great well so everyone go go follow go
follow the code to go follow tasha and
go to the website uh the website's on uh
tasha's uh uh twitter page we'll put it
up here so yeah that's gonna be uh the
uh that girl tasha blog spot and it's
gonna be uh
that girl tasha
at twitter and i'm dakota v adams on
twitter thanks dakota for joining us
my friend uh everyone stick around we'll
be right back after these messages
[Music]
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
are you annoyed by masks infringing on
your rights do you wish you didn't have
to comply with biden's communist mask
mandate are you tired of wearing masks
that actually fit your face
well now you don't have to be
introducing the droop with our patented
droop technology every mask is uniquely
molded to not fit your face just send us
a selfie and we'll have one of our
troopests mold the mask for you elastic
free thanks to the droop i don't even
need to pull my mask on anymore it just
sags that way the droop lets you
customize from a selection of pre-worn
masks lipstick stains included make sure
to order your droop today droop be the
spread you want to see in the world
[ __ ]
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
thanks for sticking around what a great
interview uh we had some breaking news
while we were off the interview
so we're going to talk about that here
stick around
stick around we're going to talk about
the zielinski address to congress
this morning also we're going to talk
about and there's gabe doing the drums
you like you like the drums you like the
drums yeah you know it's a good it gets
you pumped up you know yeah well yeah
that's why we like the rock music here
so you can really read your head yeah
uh speak speaking of uh breaking news so
we had um
the president united states speak uh
after zielinski addressed congress this
morning so i want to get to that but
before we do i want to talk just a bit
about the interview
because there has been a little bit of
news um since we dropped this interview
on uh enrique tario
here is
let's bring this in here uh mueller she
wrote posted this uh article from the
new york times this morning uh nude and
i think you we did it here new doj found
a document with a five-part plan for
january 6 in the possession of enrique
tario and included a plan to cause
trouble at a nearby building to distract
law enforcement she says makes me think
of those pipe bombs
yeah and here's the article
i'm going to go ahead and i've retweeted
this but i'll
put a thanks on here so you guys can try
to find this article if you'd like to go
read this new york times i have not read
this yet i am going to read this um as
soon after the show i i you uh you
reposting this actually yesterday um
draw my attention to it this morning so
that's a little bit of breaking news
since they arrested him since the
interview that we had with dakota on
monday that we recorded yeah i'm sure
and like dakota said i'm sure more will
come out
of uh oh i'm sure uh why no these guys
you know the oh no like they weren't
it wasn't as bad as you thought you know
just like leave it be don't don't
address it and then you're like no we
keep like we keep you know [ __ ]
scratching at this wound
and you find out that there's actually
something there's an irritated infection
you know
deep deep inside
uh and there's more to it that needs to
be addressed and uh treated and so
right well yeah i mean i mean this is a
deep disease that our country has
and i think in the interview as we tick
through with dakota and we're going to
have him on more and more because he
really he really knows this stuff when
you talk about white these militias
pairing with white nationalism because
for a long time they tried to keep white
nationalism out of a lot of these
militias like he was saying right and
that that was that was a big part of
what they were trying to do to make sure
that they weren't viewed as quote
unquote nazis right right
like that's the whole point just like
the pro-life movement doesn't want
patriot front or any other these nazi
groups being part of their protest
because they they're these are nazis not
wanting to appear to publicly be like uh
we're nazis but we're not publicly nazis
that's right that's right that's right
speaking of fascists around the world um
we had president zielinski the
pro-democracy president in ukraine speak
to our democracy this morning what is
what is hilarious about this clip let me
bring this in here um is that this is
the let me take the banner off here so
we can see this is the fox news clip
that aaron had posted this morning which
i i was really surprised that russia
news i mean excuse me fox news
uh posted zelinski praising joe biden
and democracy on their channel uh i
don't know if like because fox news has
become the content creator for russian
state tv yeah i mean like like they're
they're their main go to like we try to
find a lot of content on twitter right
put on this show but boy russian tv's
like that fox news boy we could just
roll them up 24 7. oh yeah that would be
we would be good we wouldn't have to
commentate really yeah so i i really
like the only thing that we have to do
so far is just translate right i'm
really surprised that
that uh russian news excuse me fox news
putin putin [ __ ] books news
news putin putin's uh putin news uh
whatever you want to call it right
the russians call it fox news apparently
yeah uh played the zielinski address to
congress let's let's listen to this and
then what we'll do is we'll go to the
president's remarks because president
biden actually made remarks after this
it's a little lengthy but i think we
gotta have time to play if we go ahead
and start this clip now
in your country it doesn't depend
anymore only on you and your people
it depends on those
next to you
and those who are strong
strong
doesn't mean
big
strong
is brave and ready to fight for the life
of his citizens and citizens
of the world
for human rights for freedom for the
right to live instantly and to die when
your time comes
and not when it's wanted by someone else
by your neighbor
today
the ukrainian people
are defending not only ukraine
we are fighting for the values of europe
and the world
sacrificing our lives in the name of the
future
that's why today the american people are
helping
not just ukraine
but europe
and the world to keep the planet alive
to keep justice
in history
now i am almost 45 years old
today my age stopped when the heart of
more than 100 children
stopped beating i see
no sense in life
if it cannot stop
the death
and this is my main mission as the
leader
of my people
great ukrainians
and at the leader
of my niche i am addressing
the president biden
you are the leader
of the niche
i wish you
to be the leader of the world
being the leader of the world means
to be the leader
of peace
thank you
glory to ukraine
and we see all the
[Applause]
flapping here
um for president yeah i believe the only
person who wasn't clapping was marjorie
taylor greene
at least that we could see right right
that's a good point i wouldn't be
surprised if uh lauren beaubert miss uh
lieutenant corporal uh was also not
clapping either
yeah let me let me go back and we can
show a quick clip
of what you're talking about here
marjorie taylor green and then we'll go
to the president uh because i think it
is significant because during the uh
minus touch posted here uh ben mizellis
says uh texting putin uh because minus
like what like
you know even if even if she was going
for her phone and got back up everyone
was still clapping she could have then
been like great i'll join the clap i was
just doing something with my phone
but the fact that she gets up and just
doesn't do anything she just goes to
text while everyone else is clapping and
also the fact that she can't even
acknowledge a guy that's like hey man
putin's [ __ ] killing
my people this is a [ __ ] serious
problem he's he's murdering innocent
children and people committing war
crimes for [ __ ] sake in my country and
i'm asking
for
some
some help just anything you guys got and
margie taylor green's like yeah
anyway uh yeah turn your back turn her
back on him
let's watch the video here here's the
same ending
as everyone's clapping
and here you see
marjorie taylor green turning her back
on zilinski reaching for what may seem
to be your cell phone maybe texting
putin maybe texting
uh uh other oath keepers i don't know
maybe maybe they're you know who knows i
don't know it was lauren bobert she'd be
like uh i know exactly where nancy
pelosi is yeah or or they would be like
i'm you know like
all those other people did when they had
that zoom call they'd probably be
playing like hey i'm on a call with them
right now you know and they tweet out
right and risk uh being discovered so
well it it really it really does speak
to
um
marjorie taylor green and some of her
motives
[Music]
when you're talking about this stuff a
bit yeah
yeah i mean
here's the thing
is that is that you know we can make
jokes all we want about pipe bombs and
all this stuff with marjory taylor green
but at the end of the day she is a
fascist
like that the threat and the danger as
as much as it may be and i don't know if
there there's you know something to that
but
if the threat in a danger that she poses
is obvious in that video that she is not
pro-democracy she doesn't believe in it
she believes in fascism is what she
believes in and that's where she's going
to stand behind she's going to stand
behind putin she's going to stand behind
the party of putin which is the gqp
right the p and gqp stands for putin now
it's ridiculous uh here is uh let's
let's add this to the stream here here
is president biden's remarks um
afterwards it is it is quite the video
it's about nine minutes long so uh hang
in there
we'll we'll come back after his remarks
here
good afternoon
i want to begin by thanking president
zielinski for his passionate message
this morning
i listened to it in the private
residence and
he was convincing and
significant speech
he speaks for people who have shown
remarkable courage and strength
in the face of brutal aggression
courage and strength that's inspired not
only ukrainians but the entire world
putin is inflicting an appalling
appalling devastation and horror
on ukraine
bombing apartment buildings maternity
wards hospitals
i mean it's it's god awful i was
speaking about this with
our
our our commander behind me here
general milley i mean
it's just as amazing
yesterday we saw reports that russian
forces were holding hundreds of doctors
and patients
hostage in the largest hospital in mario
pool
these are atrocities
they're an outrage to the world
and the world is united in our support
for ukraine and our determination to
make putin pay a very heavy price
america is leading this effort together
with our allies and partners providing
enormous levels of security and
humanitarian assistance that we're
adding to today and we're going to
continue to do more in the days and
weeks ahead
we're crippling putin's economy with
punishing sanctions
that's going to only grow more painful
over time with the entire
nato and eu behind us and many other
countries
what's at stake here
are the principles that the united
states and the united nations and across
the world stand for
it's about freedom
it's about the right of people to
determine their own future
it's about making sure ukraine never
will never be a victory for putin no
matter what advances he makes on the
battlefield
the american people are answering
president zielinski's call
for more help more weapons for ukraine
to defend itself more tools to fight
russian aggression
and that's what we're doing
in fact we started our assistance to
ukraine before this war began as i
started to do exercises along the
ukrainian border the russians started in
march of last year
we took the threat of putin invading
very seriously
we acted on it we sent ukraine more
security assistance last year 650
million dollars in weapons including
anti-air and anti-armor equipment before
the invasion
more than we had ever provided before
so when the invasion began they already
had in their hands the kinds of weapons
that needed to counter russian advances
and once the war started we immediately
rushed 350 million in additional aid to
further address their needs
hundreds of anti-air systems thousands
of anti-tank weapons
transport helicopters
arm patrol boats
and other high mobility vehicles radar
systems that help track incoming
artillery and unmanned drones
secure communications equipment and
tactical gear
satellite imagery and and
analysis capacity and it's clearly
helped ukraine inflict dramatic losses
on russian forces
on saturday
my administration authorized another 200
million dollars to keep a steady flow of
weapons and ammunition moving to ukraine
now i'm once again
using my presidential authority to
actively
activate an additional security
assistance to continue to help ukraine
fend off russia's assault
an additional 800 million dollars in
assistance that brings the total of new
u.s security systems to ukraine to 1
billion
just this week
these are the large these are direct
transfers of equipment from our
department of defense to the ukraine
military to help them as they fight
against this invasion
and i thank the congress for
appropriating these funds
this new package on its own is going to
provide unprecedented assistance to
ukraine
it includes 800 anti-aircraft systems
to make sure the ukrainian military can
continue to can continue to stop the
planes and helicopters that have been
attacking their people and to defend our
ukrainian airspace
and at the request of president
zielinski we have identified and are
helping ukraine acquire additional
longer-range anti-aircraft systems and
the munitions for those systems
our new assistance package
also includes 9 000 anti-armor systems
these are portable high
high accurate high accurately high
accuracy shoulder mounted missiles that
the ukrainian forces have been using
with great effect to destroy invading
tanks and armored vehicles
it'll include 7 000 small arms machine
guns shotguns grenade launchers to equip
the ukrainians including the brave women
and men who are defending their cities
as civilians and they're on the
countryside as well
and we're and we and as well as the
ammunition artillery and mortar rounds
to go with small arms 20 million rounds
in total 20 million rounds
this will include drones which
which uh demonstrates our commitment to
sending our most cutting-edge systems to
ukraine for its defense
and we're not doing this alone
our allies and partners have stepped up
to provide significant shipments of
security assistance and will continue to
help facilitate these deliveries as well
the united states and our allies and
partners are fully committed to surging
weapons of assistance to the ukrainians
and more will be coming
as we source additional stocks of
equipment that are all that we're ready
to transfer
now now i want to be honest with you
this could be a long and difficult
battle
but the american people will be
steadfast in our support of the people
of ukraine in the face of putin's
immoral unethical attacks on civilian
populations
we are united in our abhorrence of
putin's depraved onslaught
and we're going to continue to have
their backs as they fight for their
freedom their democracy their very
survival
we're going to give ukraine
the arms to fight and defend themselves
through all the difficult days ahead
we're going to continue to mobilize
humanitarian relief to support people
within ukraine and those who've been
forced to flee ukraine
in just the past few weeks we provided
300 million humanitarian assistance to
the people in ukraine and in neighboring
countries
tens of thousands of tons of food water
medicine and other basic supplies to
support the people in need
our experts on the ground in poland and
moldova
and other neighboring countries are
there to make real-time assessments of
the rapidly evolving crisis to get
urgently needed humanitarian supplies of
the people in need when they need it
and we will support ukraine's economy
with direct financial assistance as well
and together with our allies and
partners
we will keep up the pressure on putin's
crumbling economy
isolating him on the global stage
that's our goal make putin pay the price
weaken his position while strengthening
the hand of the ukrainians on the
battlefield at the negotiating table
together with our allies and partners
we're going to stay the course
and we'll do everything we can to push
for and end this tragic unnecessary war
this is a struggle to pitch the
appetites of an autocrat
against humankind's desire to be free
and let there be no doubt no uncertainty
no question
america stands with the forces of
freedom
we always have we always will
i thank you all and god bless you and
i'm going to walk over and sign this
legislative sign this bill to allow the
drawdown of those materials
there you hear the president of the
united states
um
talking about
uh
the zlinski
and
getting getting the weapons that they
need
to ukraine uh i think i think it's very
significant that we have the president
united states doing what he's doing um
here
and
you know i i don't
i don't know if uh
there's cause for huge
um
concern for the american people as far
as ground troops at this point um it
sounds like he's giving a lot of money
um in arms and support to ukrainians i
know that's probably in the back of
everyone's mind though is how far is
this gonna go what do you think gabe
uh you know it's
i think that's a hard i don't know i i'm
not sure if i really do know the answer
that i mean i can say like you know
crippling sanctions and further i mean
like here's the thing
every time putin has invaded another
country
their currency has
dipped down further and has never
recovered
uh so
this on top of sanctions the i mean the
the country is in
uh is an incredible debt right now
um
putin does not have control of his own
people right they're protesting the
streets they're willing to get jailed or
willing to be you know punished for
speaking up and saying that there should
be no war
um
and you know what was supposed to take a
mere hours or like a day at most it has
resulted in over two weeks of a
resistance by the ukrainian people and
zelinski in ukraine so
you know i look at this and i and i
wonder i don't know how long it'll last
because it's the last it's much longer
than anyone could have anticipated i
don't know of the
you know if we're if it's just uh like
you know like uh just a war of attrition
here right where it's just like kind of
whittling in a way slowly for russia to
take over but
i don't know like
this is becoming more and more like a
david and goliath situation where you
know ukraine is is david here and
and is beating everyone's expectations
whether it's a combination of
military assistance just pure [ __ ]
hatred for putin and their own
resistance you know and that like that
fire within them plus sanctions like i
don't know if it's creating a perfect
storm that's that's pushing putin
or or uh you know uh keeping him out as
long as as it is and i you know again
like i don't know how long it'll last
because
it's lasted much longer than i think
anyone would have anticipated you know
um
well and and and i think i think you
know the assistants from around the
world where people are standing up for
democracy yeah i mean you even see um
just here in the last few minutes
president zielinski tweet out uh let me
see if i can find it here tweet out
about um uh here it is uh let's bring it
up here uh this is this is him talking
about uh eric erdogan uh
if you guys know he is the
uh president of turkey who is who is not
a friend of democracy normally um even
even zielinski held talks
with him
reported on the progress of the
ukrainian people struggle against the
ongoing aggression thankful for
important support ways to intensify
peaceful dialogue we're also discussed
so like this is not just leaking out um
into like
normal
uh western democracy states
other states around the world are going
and this may be a bit further than what
we want to even go
right like the fact that you're seeing
countries like this or you're even
seeing you know uh
sweden switzerland like people that are
that are always in the past like world
war ii they're like listen guys don't
don't
no we don't want to be involved we want
to be uh neutral and right now they're
like
[ __ ] this is this is too much guys like
we can't not do anything about this so
the fact that people who were like
not silent but they're like hey we we
don't want any involvement we're just a
place where people can come and be
neutral
uh the fact that they're stepping
forward and like this is [ __ ] up like
uh we we speak we're speaking out
against russia and putin and what he's
doing
uh i think also speaks volumes right um
for for what they've seen in the past
and what they potentially believe this
could lead to if not
uh
if not stopped in its tracks you know
yeah i i think you're right um and i
know we've went a little long today but
it was worth it to see the uh zielinski
uh statements as well as the president
united states the leader of the world is
zelinski called him in the clip on fox
news which i bet putin is big jelly oh
yeah fox news aired zielinski saying
that the president of the united states
joe biden is the leader of the world
that's the way that's the way i want to
frame it [ __ ] throw some peanut butter
and you got a sandwich man that's right
that's right big big jelly um i want to
do an announcement we've got an
interview also tomorrow everyone should
tune in tomorrow anthony scaramucci the
is on the show
tomorrow um we do it we do a short
interview with with anthony scaramucci
we ask him uh questions not only about
what as what a time frame of a
scaramucci is that's important that is
important stuff to nail that down and
get an official analysis of what a
scaramucci is yep
but we also asked him about crypto we
asked him about nfts uh anthony gives
his insight into it i don't know that he
convinced me totally but i'll tell you
something his arguments
it may change your mind it may make you
think differently about crypto or nft
um again i don't i don't think he fully
convinced me but anthony is a really
smart guy he's really educated in this
stuff um but also
we'll be showing some clips later on in
social media maybe today or tomorrow
morning
uh anthony apparently he doesn't like
this guy named trump he doesn't like him
and it's weird
yeah right he's very vocal about it too
in the interview yeah in the interview
of course he does ask if he can curse
and uh we immediately told anthony yeah
we're like yeah he's like no because i
love to say [ __ ] you know oh [ __ ]
filter here on the tony michaels podcast
so tune in tomorrow if you're not
subscribed to the youtube channel uh
you're not going to want to miss the the
interview with anthony scaramucci
tomorrow
on the tony michaels podcast we'll again
we'll send some clips out so you guys
can see some of that in advance but here
tomorrow on the tony michaels podcast uh
join us tomorrow noon eastern 11 central
as always same time same place every
single weekday
until tomorrow everybody surfs up
[ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels footcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking